elise et donne le ton et parle d'un
discours de conquête et de combat
pour emmanuel macron il s'agirait là de
l'acte 1 d'une série d'initiatives à
venir contre les forces obscurantistes
et les replis communautaires
selon l'entourage du président français
plusieurs phénomènes bat en brèche comme
le droit au blasphème mais aussi un
recul de la liberté d'expression les
proches des manuels macron pointe du
doigt le séparatisme islamistes
l'extrême droite et l'extrême gauche
cause des maux de la république
autre exemple pris par l'entourage du
président le déboulonnage de statut
expliquant que la république pourra
corriger mais n'efface pas vous
comprenez l'histoire un discours d'
emmanuel macron qui prépare également
les français à une future loi promise
pour l'automne le président a donc remis
en route un dossier lancé en février
dernier est interrompue pour cause de
crise sanitaire
lors d'un déplacement dans un quartier
populaire de mulhouse
emmanuel macron avait alors annoncé un
plan contre le séparatisme islamistes un
projet qui stipulait la fin des imams
étrangers détachées et un contrôle du
financement des mosquées
l'allocution présidentielle de ce
vendredi n'est pas un discours
sécuritaire rassure cependant son
entourage
soucieux de séparer les deux thématiques
un thème devenu cependant centrale dans
les propos d' emmanuel macron comme de
ses ministres qui dénoncent tous la
banalisation de la violence et
promettent d